[Musique]
voilà
tu connais week du participatif c'est du
collaboratif
c'est pas le premier et ce qu'elles
gagnent que je fais et attention ce ne
sera pas le dernier
ça je peux vous lire on se retrouve dans
55 minutes
orsoni
on doit sortir des soldes alors la voix
du nord dans la sphère frappé le reste
ira ps du lot écrite et c'est eux béat
mais c'est de trouver à mango
félicitations vous avez réussi à lever
la malédiction de la momie vous avez
terminé votre mission à deux minutes de
la fin les ménages en selle et las vegas
félicitations le jeu super cool nasa
prévoit que je sais mais je pensais pas
que ça serait aussi la première fois
qu'on fasse ce qu'elle vienne avec un
humain dans le décor la gêne chez nous
oui
[Musique]
je
vous ne mesurez pas ce que vous avez
déclenché qu'est ce que c'est que ce
délire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment tu as fait pour s'échapper de
l'appareil tu n'as pas la moindre
égratignure
vous êtes en vie parce que vous avez été
maudit maudit par qui le mal suprême
bienvenue dans un nouveau monde
peuplé de dieux et de monstres
il
tu as vu la même chose que moi
elle a changé quelque chose en moi
la quintessence du mal vous anime
désormais
tadic à celui là gagnent
j'ai peur
il faut un monstre
pour combattre un monstre
enfants
enfin
je m'attache à ce matin
oh
[Musique]